merci d'être en direct avec nous sur air
france à l'élimination du leader
d'al-qaida au maghreb c'est une victoire
pour l'armée française et la force
barkan comme le déclare florence parler
oui c'est une victoire mais c'est une
victoire symbolique le leader comme
s'est présenté d'accueil n'est qu'un des
nombreux émirs qui malheureusement
continuent à tuer dans cette région 4000
civils sont morts en 2010 9500 soldats
des forces armées sahélienne également
et on le sait malheureusement 43
français dont le dernier le 4 mai
dernier donc c'est une victoire
symbolique avec si j'ose dire un vieux
un vieux studio boutique de la lutte
anti tank de la lutte terroriste dans la
région at-elle malek troupel comme c'est
indiqué sur votre carte et est d'origine
algérienne c'est la raison pour laquelle
il a été mis hors d'état de nuire dans
une région bien précise celle du reste
ou avait été menée des premiers combats
de location serval celle qui avait
précédé le passé par cannes ont ce qu'on
appelle l'adrar des ifoghas donc dans
une zone dans lequel un certain nombre
de groupes armés terroristes avaient
déjà trouvé refuge en 2013
donc c'est une victoire purement
symbolique premièrement il n'est par le
chef du groupe de soutien de mme à
l'islam et aux musulmans
le chef en question court toujours il
s'agit du touareg ilya dall ghali qui
évidemment est éminemment vous
recherchez deuxièmement le l'élimination
de ce chef terroriste et va de pair avec
une autre réalité qui nous amène à la
lutte que les les forces armées
françaises et du reste des forces armées
internationales dans le cadre de la
minustah continue à mener dans une autre
région du mali qui est celle dite de la
région des trois frontières communément
donc entre le mali le niger et le
burkina faso avec un autre groupe
armé terroriste l'état islamique dans le
grand sahara alors que florence parly a
annoncé il ya quelques heures le décès
d'albert n'avait qu'un truc belle a été
annoncée également l'arrestation d'un
autre chef historique du salafisme ou du
jihad armé au sahel en l'occurrence al
maghribi de son prénom mohamed
alain rabat qui lui est un autre une
autre réalité qui correspond par une
autre réalité de la lutte anti
terroriste de la lutte contre les
groupes armés terroristes donc avec une
résurgence des attaques menées contre
les français et contre les forces
maliennes et les forces nigérianes et il
est fort ce burkina faso de berkeley
faso par l'état islamique donc il ya
aussi une surenchère dans la lutte entre
les groupes armés terroristes qui
parfois se font la guerre entre eux
aussi qu'est ce qu'on sait à l'heure
actuelle les circonstances de la mort à
la fois daniel malingue dont daleh de
ses proches collaborateurs alors écoutez
moi c'est bien un petit peu tôt je n'ai
pas les éléments les éléments
d'appréciation néanmoins ce que l'on
peut retenir de cette opération c'est
que elle montre elle démontre que les
forces armées françaises singulièrement
les samedis 5200 militaires français qui
sont tous engagés la marcal 2500 au mali
continue à mener la guerre dans l'obs
temps évidemment la menace de du grenade
virus deuxièmement ce qu'il faut retenir
aussi dans la manière dont ça qu'annoncé
c'est le fait qu'on a évoqué le fait que
cette opération était menée en
partenariat est notamment partenaire et
les forces armées locales
c'est particulièrement important au
moment où ses forces armées locales
n'ont en l'occurence malienne mais on
pourrait élargir aux forces armées
nigériennes et le kenya baise sont
soumis à une forte pression
un récent rapport de l'onu évoque la
multiplication des exactions de ces
mêmes forces armées locales
on évoque d'ailleurs la multiplication
et la sauce idées et des exécutions
extrajudiciaires et sur un autre volet
celui la corruption ou détournement de
fonds une vaste enquête montre à quel
point les forces armées nigériennes et
des forces armées maliennes ont besoin
entre guillemets de faire le ménage chez
elle donc il ya l'avait il y à la
nécessité aussi d'annoncer le fait que
les forces françaises n'ont pas agi seul
et qu'elles ont pu bénéficier de ce
partenariat avec les forces que nous
appelons à renforcer dans le cadre du g
500 arrestations d'un côté dans la
région des trois frontières et cette
mise hors d'état de nuire dans le nord
du mali vient nous rappeler que les
groupes armés terroristes agissant des
zones différentes qu'il faut sans doute
renforcer la coopération internationale
et l'autre message que je retiens c'est
que cette action arrive à un moment où
les européens doutent des opérations que
nous menons nous français un peu seul
il faut bien le dire depuis depuis 2013
et que il a eu encore il ya quelques
heures à rome une demande très forte en
l'occurrence celle de jean yves le drian
d'associer nos partenaires les italiens
ont promis de nous aider aussi
dans cette perspective en montre un très
concrètement quelle peut être les
répercussions de la mort de son leader
da q mais sur le mouvement djihadiste je
crois que je crains qu'elle ne soit pas
très forte
c'est un des émirs comme je le rappelais
du reste il faut avoir à l'esprit que
abdelmalek trop de belles allons passer
derrière lui c'est un ancien des groupe
salafiste de prédication de combat c'est
un ancien des groupes islamiques armés
sont postés criminels remonte aux années
90 du reste les et les algériens avaient
failli l'arrêter en 2009 elle avait un
petit peu perdu sa trace durant les
dernières années est donc fort
heureusement les militaires français ont
mis fin à son triste a sont à sa triste
carrière si j'ose dire
néanmoins il faut avoir à l'esprit que à
des mâles et groupe bel était fortement
général c'est-à-dire critiquer mais en
tout cas était fortement interrogé sur
son leadership premièrement il n'avait
pas prêté allégeance à al qaïda au
moment où ben laden a été tué en 2011 il
n'a jamais reconnu l'autorité d'al
zawahiri
deuxièmement comme je le disais
précédemment les groupes armés
terrorisent que ce soit avec la guidance
islamique
que ce soit le moment de servir ou
moujawar ont fusionné en l'occurrence
sous l'égide du groupe de soutien à
l'islam et aux musulmans qui est dirigé
par l'autre chef qui lui continue à
mener la vie dure aux forces armées
locales et aux forces armées européennes
et françaises et internationales qui est
le touareg il est à égalité donc je ne
crois je crains malheureusement que ce
ne soit qu'une victoire symbolique elle
est importante elle est importante aussi
à ce qu'elle est advenu à la frontière
avec l'algérie
il y a quelques jours les l'assemblée
nationale algérienne a sondé populaire
nationale algérienne a voté la mise en
place d'un nouveau dispositif qui
permettrait à l'armée algérienne de
sortir de son territoire pour évidemment
mené aussi des actions antiterroristes
oxydes peut-être l'occasion de rappeler
que pour mettre un terme
malheureusement au kiss qui n'a
malheureusement pas été le cas jusqu'à
présent aux exactions des groupes armés
terroristes
c'est avant tout en élargissant la
coopération et en multipliant les
partenariats avec les forces armées
locales
merci beaucoup emmanuel dupuy je
rappelle que vous êtes un président de
l'institut et prospective et sécurité
elle de l'europe